[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti io sono valeria e
questo è il mio violino sapete stiamo
insieme da molto tempo ormai
dunque è difficile per un artista
riuscire a descrivere che cosa questo
strumento rappresenti per la propria
vita
questo violino grazie al quale ho
vissuto esperienze conosciuto persone
previsto luoghi che altrimenti
difficilmente avrei incontrato allo
stesso modo perché quando ti dicono che
bello che riesce a fare della tua
passione il tuo mestiere ti piace è la
musica
in realtà è un po come se ti chiedessero
ti piace respirare perché per un artista
esprimersi attraverso il suo strumento
qualunque esso sia qualcosa che va oltre
la passione e il divertimento il piacere
come una ricerca sul senso stesso della
vita la musica poi arte tra tutte la più
eterea ed impalpabile e al contempo
materia così terribilmente umana
ciò che vorrei portare qui oggi è
infatti un'esperienza molto forte che ho
vissuto recentemente in cui ho vissuto
veramente la il lato umano della musica
nella sua maniera più universale e di
quanto essa veramente sia stata capace
di andare oltre
vi sto parlando appunto di questa
esperienza che ho vissuto lo scorso 19
gennaio in iran un concerto
a cui ho partecipato come membro della
young musicians european orchestra
condotta dal maestro paolo olmi appunto
la musica da mezzo di espressione e
condivisione personale a mezzo di unione
e integrazione ecco qui ci vedete
appunto una delegazione qui in foto
si tratta di un vero e proprio concerto
evento perché era da quasi 40 anni e dal
rivoluzione islamica del 79 che
un'orchestra sinfonica occidentale non
si esibiva più sul suolo iraniano
diciamo qui per l'occasione si sono
riunite insieme tre orchestre qui in
foto vedete young musicians european
orchestra di cui ho fatto parte insieme
all'orchestra del festival puccini di
torre del lago insieme a rappresentare
l'italia che si sono poi unite alla
teheran symphony orchestra
questo era appunto il manifesto
dell'evento li evento sold out dopo
poche ore dalla vendita dei biglietti
presso la vada all di teheran ad
indicare proprio la7 di questo paese di
riaprirsi all'occidente e alla grande
musica colta occidentale vediamo qualche
foto dell'evento
qui stavamo appunto suonando la quinta
sinfonia di beethoven in apertura del
concerto i due inni
italiano ed iraniano 90 in tutto i
musicisti coinvolti
abbiamo detto tre orchestre fuse insieme
ma anche tre direttori una cosa
abbastanza anomala per un concerto e qui
si sono alternati paolo olmi alberto
veronesi e shahrdad roani qui vedete
anche me
appunto in ogni leggio un italiano un
iraniano insieme proprio simbolo di
questa unione di questa amicizia
le donne velate perché in iran legge qui
vedete ancora meglio che era una vera e
propria impresa riuscire a farlo super
che cadeva sempre giù con le mollette
anche è un'arte anche quella qui anche
durante le prove generali in teatro
perché appunto va portato sempre queste
l'insegna dell'ambasciata italiana a
teheran iran e italia due paesi che
ratano molto in comune già a partire
dalla la bandiera se notiamo ma molto di
più dal senso di ospitalità della
l'importanza della tradizione il senso
della famiglia la bontà della cucina
oltre
inoltre anche di ram è un paese che
sente davvero e vive molto la musica
dunque io ho avuto la fortuna di vivere
diverse esperienze in contesti
internazionali sia di studio che con
certi però vi posso veramente assicurare
che quella sera in quel teatro è
successo qualcosa perché è stato come
veramente se tutti ci fossimo uniti in
un unico abbraccio anche se questo vi
parlo da donna concretamente fisicamente
non sarebbe stato possibile perché sui
volti di tutti c'era uno splendido
sorriso i cuori spalancati il pubblico
in visibilio veramente due mondi che si
uniscono riuscendo ad integrarsi come
un'unica cosa allora quello che io
voglio dire diciamo che la musica è un
linguaggio universale universale la
musica che parla la musica d'arte
portatrice di messaggi ma è forse ci
stiamo dimenticando che se la musica
riesce
ad essere universale perché noi siamo
uno la musica con tutte le sue diversità
le sue forme ed espressioni differenti è
una e noi umanità nonostante tutte le
nostre differenze restiamo una questo
non dovremmo dimenticarlo mai
per cui guardando al futuro rimaniamo
aperti curiosi uniti
apriamo le nostre porte e impariamo ad
ascoltarci a sentirci come fa con noi la
musica
quello che vorrei io suonarvi adesso è
un brano che ho composto dopo il mio
invito a ted in cui appunto si chiama
kid and love amore nascosto proprio ad
indicare quanto amore realtà ci siano ha
scosso nel mondo che noi dobbiamo ancora
scoprire o che non siamo ancora pronti a
cogliere e vorrei lasciarvi con una
riflessione vuole essere un abbraccio
che va oltre come nella mia esperienza
iraniana attraverso la musica di cui
sentirete i richiami sparo vi piacerà
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ora
o
no
[Musica]
[Applauso]